yeah austin is it changing
you've got oh yeah a lot of people from
california moving in
you got probably people from new york
that went there is it changing
and are you going to be okay with this
new austin
you know the world's always changing so
i'm very comfortable with it i actually
like
all the new people i just don't like the
big
tech corporations that have come in that
are pushing their politics but i think
the city overall
a lot of folks that have been fleeing
the worst parts of california which is a
great state by the way i've been room on
the left
and and people fleeing you know new york
everywhere else because the lockdown
i mean i think they brought a lot of
money and energy and ideas
and the restaurants are better and the
comedy's better and quite frankly i'm
just sitting there
getting the french benefits off of all
these amazing people moving to austin so
yeah
so you're supportive of everybody coming
absolutely i don't like the mayor two
years ago going if you're homeless come
live here
because then like joe exposed last week
on the show hundreds of millions of
dollars in l.a alone to the managers
that manage the homeless
so i don't think you should just like
camp in somebody's front yard and use
fentanyl all day
so no i don't like the democrat
politicians moving to austin and
bringing what they do
but the people fleeing democrats are
great and republicans aren't perfect
either but the people fleeing those
policies are great
the democrats coming with them aren't so
like the democrats slaves
run away want to be free and here come
all the democrat policies i don't like
that part
but i love the people [ __ ] i mean
there's like austin always had a model
great restaurant now it's like
ridiculous it's got comedy anywhere you
want to go
you've got all these films getting shown
music i mean it's it's it's it's pretty
amazing
you don't worry it's going to become
like san francisco from a texan
oh i'm sure it's going to get
overpopulated austin to me is just san
fran 15 years ago
it's about to get infiltrated with tech
money it started like this kind of weird
little
gem city that people in the state knew
about but i think a lot of tech
companies are moving in and it's going
to just become san francisco i agree
that it's going to probably go bad yeah
that and everything all right yeah
okay we've come a long way together
that one or is even mo what's one about
like i'd stand in line for this
and then all of a sudden it goes bad
yeah you know i trust you
moby that's not moby what's the one i
don't know i've had a few
whatever okay next question
next question we're doing serious
questions here no no i want to talk
about everything i'll talk about
epstein i went visited his pervert
palace you did yeah
when uh yesterday how was it the day
before
uh it says it sold 25 million
seven-story building where royalty and
globalists and top tech heads went to
have sex with underage girls to be
compromised
in their club it's like a people go do
they know they're being compromised of
course they're being
brought into a cult it's a it's a rite
of passage
uh it's an initiation so we covered that
it's pretty amazing and what was that
like
it's just creepy to know that the whole
system knew and then after the fbi
raided it when finally epstein died
after they left and went a bunch of guys
with suitcases because they had the
hidden wall and the whole
and they got all the good stuff and ran
out with it it's pretty bad
and you don't think we'll ever see it i
mean we know what happened epstein was
just one example of
they they corrupt people with basically
things that are illegal drugs
money kids everything and i'm just
surprised there's a big enough market to
compromise the
academia and the government with kids i
mean because i'm not into kids
and so i have a real problem you know
understanding how people are but there's
again enough of these weird kind of
creepy nerd dudes
who like just like they're scared of
women they're scared of even whenever
they like that power of it's a kid like
they're over it and everything
and so i mean i have to tell you you
make jokes about dream of chrome and i
do too cause i don't know thompson wrote
about it it turns out
you know adrena chrome is real no it's a
real compound it's really cool
oh oh yes in terms of like it's physical
chemistry it exists in the world
yeah conor s thompson wrote about it to
fear and loathing whenever he published
that was in the early 80s or late in the
70s i don't know 70s i think
okay so he publishes that and talks
about a satanist giving him adrenal
chrome
and his lawyer gives it to me he's
really however then in the 90s a company
the clintons are connected to patents
the epipen
and it says on the package you can pull
it up adrenochrome
an epipen is for people who are have
diabetes or something like that
they have anaphylactic shocks like bee
stings yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and so
and so yes yes yes yes and so it says
right on it
adrenochrome and so i was like is this
real but
the yes it's been confirmed in like the
uk they caught groups doing it whether
whether they're really getting hot
or not they torture a kid scare them
really bad then
slice their throat open and then they
drink the blood and they think they're
getting high off the stuff so
is it actually some drug that's out
there hunter s thompson said it was real
now it's on an epipen
uh you know but again only the un's
allowed to give up medical advice so
we better fact check that pull up the
epipen it says adrenochrome on it
and i'm not saying that pen has has
stuff of kids it's a synthetic like he
said adrenaline
yeah i don't like fact checking you i
like letting you go no but they'll lie
about you and say that we said that had
that
we're not saying nothing we say is real
all this is like yeah this is all
hyperbole but only susan wachowski has
rights
she is do you know what that is the
[ __ ] matrix
sisters were the wachowski brothers they
made the matrix
and then they transitioned i mean the
woman that actually just ceo
okay it's way better though
yeah it's so good the other way they
asked me like in a vanity fair article
like 10 years ago
do you like them you know a bunch of
them they go do you
do you think that what show ski brother
is good transitioning
and i said yeah great they're an adult
it was in the quote i mean i don't give
a [ __ ] you're [ __ ] old dude or
whatever you want to be a woman go ahead
but the point is don't try to teach
five-year-olds about that yeah i don't
care if you're heterosexual homosexual
whatever you are
leave kids alone and let them chase
butterflies man
yeah i think that that's pretty i think
most people agree on that
and what and the fact that that is
controversial in any way
is absurd because i think if 95 percent
of people
or well 95 people would agree with what
you said
right yeah the [ __ ] kids alone it's
pretty easy
now here's my question
disney right creates a lot of great
content
has these young stars these young stars
end up really flaming out at young ages
for the most part i mean a lot of them
too many
yeah a too large a percentage compared
to the average population yeah i don't
think show business for children is good
on average
okay go go on that though so it's not
specifically disney it's just show
business in general
and why is that we have a theory we
discussed
because the children get told what to do
from the beginning they're not being
themselves
just like we're as adults with with
executives trying to tell us what to do
it's not healthy
these children are put up there they're
put on a pedestal they make money their
parents tell them to do it
they behave like trained seals they're
around a bunch of corrupt you know
powerful rich people and you know money
on average
you know can be very destructive unless
you make it all about your art and your
mission
i'm like you know you guys are very
successful you're you know keeping it
you know real here in brooklyn
doing your deal if you try to go to l.a
guaranteed to have more fights with your
girlfriends your wives
you'd have more issues it's it's like
it's just that proximity to that old
decadent system
uh i mean have you seen it disney not
gonna have disney in past i mean
how they hired convicted pedophiles to
be directors over children's movies wait
really oh yeah look it up
uh fact check that and let him let him
censor that now
now they're covering up no no no no type
in disney
hire convicted pedophile to direct
children's show
it's all there i mean like it's a club
and we ain't in it
and so uh mark you had a point about the
the disney kids or maybe it was about
like child actors
and you likened it to being molested
what was the point again i don't
remember exactly but like
once you're in the system and you
receive like fame and
money and riches all at a super young
age does it emotionally stun you
ah yeah yeah does it give you like i was
ignoring you say it again
if you had trump calling literally sorry
not brag it's funny you call right now
wait
pick it up no it's already done call him
back
dog call him back call him back this
would be
hilarious no no you can't do that when
the number goes through it's like a
secretary that i mentioned
ah they all hear him in new york it's
crazy i don't know what's going on
it wasn't a name drop it was just funny
that happened you haven't called me like
a year invite him to dinner
you